good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight cheerful in spite of it
all we have spent an awful lot of time
telling you what we think about the
biden administration we do it virtually
every night a little repetitive
so tonight for once we are going to let
the biden administration speak for
itself
this show has obtained some recently
shot footage of joe biden and kamal
harris the president and vice president
of the united states or vice versa
depending on your view
footage that shows them in their private
moments deep within the federal compound
in washington it is a remarkable window
into who these people really are and
maybe the most remarkable thing about it
is that this video comes from the biden
administration itself
they released it apparently on purpose
they wanted you to see it they thought
you would be impressed they thought it
would make them look good
keep that in mind as you watch this
first clip
this footage is from kamala harris's
quote surprise birthday party the other
day here it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the entire history of sad parties
that has got to take first place talk
about a murthy event it's like a room
full of aliens have gathered to act out
this concept they just heard about
called happiness
the head alien is a supernaturally
strange being called kamala harris who
for reasons no one ever explains walks
into a room in the most secure building
in the world with a piece of elasticized
fabric over her face like that's totally
normal just another masked birthday
celebration
this kamala harris then walks over to a
man press reports claim is her husband
who like her is fully vast
he for some reason is a mask on his face
too
would suggest that they don't actually
live together or indeed have ever met
we don't know the truth but whatever it
is the two then proceed to pantomime the
most sexless imitation of a kiss
imaginable awkwardly rubbing faces
through the gauze
and then
as if it could get weirder harris
suddenly yells surprise at her own
surprise birthday party like she's
hosting the event for one of her
multiple personalities
what the hell is going on here who are
these people oh just our leaders the
people who run the country and then it
gets truly bizarre take a look at this
video again intentionally released by
the white house press office of joe
biden in a hallway
he totters along like a nursing home
patient in the final stretch clearly
unaware of his surroundings or what he's
carrying in his own hands spoiler alert
their flowers
watch
really
this is my favorite
got it thank you oh i'm gonna hang this
up with great pride thank you mr
president
the camera catches her masked alone in
her own office and then she talks oh joe
i'm very touched says this alien posing
as vice president she goes on to use the
word gorgeous a word that no actual
human being has used since 1977.
there's even if you listen for it a fake
kiss sound in there
we're assuming harris made that sound
though it's possible they're playing
some sort of soundtrack in the
background lifelike party sounds volume
one we can't be certain what we do know
is that they wanted you to see this and
that is interesting
you can tell a lot about a regime by the
propaganda it produces north korea puts
out a ton of propaganda just the other
day kim's government released a video of
its soldiers breaking concrete slabs
with their bare hands
one particularly committed communist
lies down shirtless on shards of broken
glass
so the message here is not hard to
understand these are the people
defending north korea back off or we'll
eat you
okay got it
but what's the message of the joe and
kamala videos
all your nightmares are real the people
in charge are even worse than you
thought they were
common may have seemed kind of fake to
you joe may have looked a little out of
it but actually the white house is now
telling us you don't know the half of it
it's possible kamala harris is an actual
robot with batteries the new frontier of
a.i
joe biden isn't just punchy he's barely
conscious
that's the message they're sending
it's really strange and it's been going
on for a while
remember last year when joe biden read
from a note card that kamala harris
would be his vice president
this was the announcement video they
released
hi hi hi sorry to keep you that's all
right
you ready to go to work
oh my god i'm so ready to go to work
first of all is the answer yes the
answer is absolutely yes joe and i'm
ready to work i am ready to do this with
you for you i i just i just deeply
honored and i'm very excited
whoa that's just beyond belief
so why would the people around joe biden
want the public to see something like
that maybe they don't care maybe they're
not embarrassed of joe biden's condition
maybe in fact his condition was the
whole point of making him the democratic
nominee for president in the first place
that's not unimaginable it's happened
there's precedent for it
in 1617 a group of unscrupulous
political operatives in istanbul
installed a mentally defective man as
sultan of the entire ottoman empire his
name was mustafa the first historians
later referred to him as mustafa the mad
and he certainly was that
mustafa spent his days babbling like an
infant and throwing coins to birds
occasionally if he was feeling sporty he
would knock the turbine off someone
else's head he was completely demented
the general population didn't know that
of course the sultan really left the
palace and when he did he spoke from a
script
but the people around him certainly knew
they preferred him that way he was
easier to control
whatever you think of him joe biden is
definitely easy to control you recall
this clip in which biden kept referring
to something called the harris biden
administration
harris biden administration is going to
relaunch that effort and keep pushing
further to make it easier for military
spouses and veterans to find meaningful
careers
again these are prepared remarks we
can't say that enough these are
statements that the biden people are
making voluntarily so many of them are
like that
they're not gaffs
they're what they want you to see
in december of last year kamal harris
who grew up in canada a foreign country
swore that she witnessed quote multiple
generations of her family celebrating
kwanzaa an american holiday that was
invented in long beach california after
kamala harris was born
my sister and i we grew up celebrating
kwanzaa every year our family would in
our extended family we would gather
around across multiple generations
and we tell stories the kids would sit
on the carpet and the elders would sit
in chairs so to everyone who was
celebrating happy kwanzaa from our
family to yours
our family
that's just crazy but they would put
something like that out not one word is
true but not one word is believable
again it was a prepared statement it was
carefully considered didn't even bother
to look at a calendar
it was like when kamala harris said that
tupac was the best rapper alive 23 years
after he died
when you're making history you don't
care about chronology or facts
we've never had a vice president who
looks like kamala harris so words no
longer matter that's the real message
all that matters is what kamala harris
looks like she's our martin luther king
in 1965 the actual martin luther king
told the story about a civil rights
march in birmingham alabama and at that
march a police officer asked a young
girl who was present what do you want
in king's telling quote the little girl
looked at him straight in the eye and
answered feed him
that was 1965.
here's kamala harris's version of the
same story this time starring martin
luther king's modern reincarnation
kamala harris she would tell the story
about houston they're marching
and this is back when strollers didn't
really have arm rest and seat belts
[Laughter]
so
they're marching away and you know
shouting and and all of that and then i
think it was my uncle freddie you know
looked down and looked in the stroller
which was empty
and said where's carl
and apparently it left me like a block
behind i'd fallen
there you go and then my mother would
tell a funny story about how like one
day she did and i was fussing and you
know and so i'm fussing and fussing she
it's much cuter when she would tell the
story but she'd say so then she would
look down at me and come live what do
you want what do you want and i looked
back up and i said freedom
[Laughter]
[Applause]
wow
ladies and gentlemen that's arm martin
luther king the canadian version except
without the wisdom the insight the
restraint or the eloquence but
with a brand new highly creepy
engineered laugh a noise that according
to zoologist scares the hell out of
squirrels and other small woodland
creatures but maybe you like it maybe
you want to hear a whole lot more
terrifyingly cringy fake laughter from a
highly ambitious lady with dead eyes the
white house is betting that you do
so to accommodate your bottomless
appetite for being patronized by kamala
harris they released this video in which
she talks about space
i just love the idea of exploring the
unknown
and then there's other things that we
just haven't figured out or discovered
yet to think about so much that's out
there that we still have to learn
like i love that i love that and so i'm
very excited about the space council
you guys are gonna see you're gonna
literally see the craters on the moon
with your own eyes oh my goodness with
your own eyes i'm telling you it is
going to be
unbelievable
i'm telling you oh
okay
it's funny you imagine often that the
truth is hidden away we'll never really
get to what the truth is
but in fact very often the truth is
right there it's right on the video just
look at the video that's the truth it's
the truth they want you to see anyway
and for that reason is deeply revealing
that video tells you everything one of
those kids
listening to kamala harris talk about
space we later learned was a child actor
and yet he was still the most genuine
person in that video
it's kind of nuts when you think about
it
these people literally have no idea how
absurd they look and how could they they
live in a tiny airless cult where
everyone pretends that joe biden is
fully competent kamala harris is a civil
rights hero it's jonestown
the clips we displayed are the
documentary evidence that historians the
future will study to figure out what
happened to america
behind the heavily guarded walls of the
white house everyone has gone crazy
just this week the buy administration
declared that a biological man who wears
a dress is now a female admiral
and then they sent that brave four-star
female admiral out to deliver a speech
that read like something out of a d-day
documentary watch
i am truly honored to join the ranks of
men and women across this great nation
who have committed to defend the united
states against small and large threats
known and unknown
i am honored to serve as the first
female four-star officer
of the u.s public health service
commissioned corps
come on they're daring you to sit there
and not say this is ridiculous but it is
sorry it is ridiculous sorry not playing
along
but they don't think it is
and so you have to ask yourself how long
will it be before joe biden appoints his
horse to the supreme court
and when he inevitably does do that you
have to ask how long will be until cnn
informs us this is a watershed moment
for equine rights don't you dare laugh
that would be a hate crime hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else